la tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo mio
video oggi siamo su un'altra storia e
lina questa storia è successa con la mia
prima
ragazza dopo che abbiamo avuto ma la
nostra prima volta che ho già spiegato
in un altro video che è andata insomma
un po così così da quella volta lì
noi abbiamo vissuto la nostra storia
molto bene ci siamo sbloccati anche dal
punto di vista insomma dell'intimità
siamo sbloccati e non abbiamo avuto più
quel problema però dal punto di vista
dell'intimità andava tutto bene questa
frase sono riuscita pure a dirla in
family friendly che è magnifico comunque
siccome andava tutto bene è che vuoi far
andare tutto bene
eh no e poi vi chiedete come mai vi
siete lasciati e per qualche motivo ci
sarà pure raccontiamo questa storia che
anche la diretta interessata sarà
orgogliosa di sentire non cridge era per
niente come non lo farò nemmeno io
pensai che la sua pure raccontandovi
questi non hanno segnato io non so
neanche come descrivereste rock dove
vorrei evitare di nominare l'eventuale
persona per preservare la privacy io la
chiamerò in questo video grace hall da
preservare la privacy una sega perché
tanto nei primi video del canale c'è
anche lei quindi di che cosa stiamo
parlando di iniziare al fatto che come
vi ho già detto come avrete sicuramente
già visto in quel video magnifico che ho
fatto la nostra prima volta non è stata
al massimo perché era la prima volta e
quindi abbiamo avuto quel problema di
poi come vi ho detto prima ci siamo
sbloccati e tutto fino a che fino a che
non è successa una roba un po po po così
siamo andati in vacanza insieme
il che è fantastico perché erano passati
solo un quartiere ha passato qualche
mese da quando siamo messi insieme
quindi noi siamo stati messi insieme ad
aprile nel mese di aprile e ad agosto
eravamo già in vacanza insieme che
incredibile perché i nostri genitori non
ci facevano fare una mazza però se
andate in vacanza insieme ad agosto e
che è stato assurdo bellissimo dato mi
sono divertito tantissimo
tranne per quello che vi sto per
raccontare però è stata una bellissima
vacanza c'eravamo io lei i miei genitori
e i suoi genitori quando si è in vacanza
stavamo ci divertivamo insomma e abbiamo
cercato anche un po di intimità come ho
detto prima avevamo più stanze
ovviamente diverse cioè c'erano i miei
genitori ho i miei genitori stavamo in
una stanza lei con i suoi genitori stava
in un'altra però c'erano i momenti
durante la giornata in cui sia i miei
genitori se i suoi genitori andavano in
spiaggia
cosa fai quando i genitori vanno in
spiaggia giochi a carte giochi alla
playstation
c'era la misteriosa cominciano le carte
allora insomma ci si intratteneva con
tromba e allora insomma siccome le
stanze erano libere abbiamo deciso di
andare in una delle stanze ovviamente
abbiamo deciso la sua entrava distanza
sua siccome non troppo tempo in quei
giorni perché comunque i momenti liberi
hanno veramente pochi abbiamo sfruttato
insomma tempo che avevamo
e successo che entriamo in camera sua
eravamo entrambi contenti e lei
esordisce dicendo una cosa no ciò le mie
cose
va bene non vedo l'ora proprio tutto
figo anche io ero come sapete tutti i
veri cavalieri hanno anche la spada
insanguinata comunque nel discorso
comunque è che aveva poco tempo c'era
non potevamo fare niente di esagerato
in quei giorni quindi sfruttavamo
insomma dai vabbè
chissenefrega ci togliamo i vestiti per
dire questa frase abbiamo preso gol
comincia insomma fare le nostre cose
madonna che kringe allora senza la
comporta così c'era l'entrata ok a
sinistra c'era il bagno dopo il bagno
c'era la stanza da letto la stanza non
era così grossa una stanza d'albergo
ciao stanza da letto rai eravamo sul
letto finisce c'è finisce in una sega
dice no nel senso taglio st parte nel
mentre che stavamo facendo insomma un po
di roba cioè mentre che vabbè avete
capito
sentiamo un rumore magico perché
presente gli alberghi hanno tutti il
vano della tessera per inserire la
tessera noi sentiamo che quando tu metti
la tessera si sente il classico rumore
di sblocco della porta si tiente claque
ok che sismica nel momento che noi
stavamo facendo la nostra roba sentiamo
claque e la porta magica mente si
sblocca eravamo 9 questo non posso
raccontarlo mentre gioco a rocket league
quindi abbandonerò amy mi ammazzeranno
mi banner anno la gameplay vabbè fa
niente a questo punto devo devo proprio
concentrarmi perché è stata una cosa
cioè ancora ancora non ho problemi a
vabbè lo chiamo istantaneamente
sgraniamo entrambi gli occhi così faccio
la cosa peggiore che io abbia mai fatto
in tutta la mia vita partiamo dal
presupposto che sono germo fobico c a me
fanno schifo i germi che io quando vado
in m mi fa schifo tocca al pub sento
claque io come un fulmine celle stava
insomma io ero sdraiato faccio lei stava
davanti io faccio
lancio buca 1 mi lancio fuori dal letto
nudo mi infilo sotto il letto nudo
completamente nudo mi fido sotto letto
così
mamma mia che schifo io mentre mentre
nono globo se spiace veramente uno
schifo
uno schifo uno schifo e io ero sotto il
letto entra nella stanza mi pare sua
mamma ma non è arrivata in camera da
letto però era entrata subito nel bagno
che era subito a sinistra ha preso una
roba al volo ed è uscita mamma mia io mi
sono pagato fosse ho veramente
raccontato questa storia su youtube io
va beh l'ho raccontata è successo
davvero la nostra scherza poi sentori
chiudersi la porta ho tirato un sospiro
di sollievo incredibile
sono uscito dal letta sotto il letto mi
sono ficcato con la testa nella doccia
che schifo orribile somma ben sa è stata
quella volta che ci hanno quasi racconto
un altro alla veloce allora questa è
stata la volta questo e questa era il
maine racconto meiner a questo sono
stata un'altra poi rivolta in cui vi vi
accenno un paio di aneddoti simili
c'è stata una volta qui siamo andati in
vacanza insieme però stavolta eravamo
solo io e lei ei suoi genitori eravamo
al lago di garda sono ricantato
bellissimo un posto bellissimo
siamo andati a gardaland bellissimo e
niente allora io avevo la mia stanza e
loro avevano la loro la sera uscivamo
tutti quanti insieme
ma c'erano alcune sere in cui i genitori
ci lasciano liberi cioè uscivano loro
due e uscivamo noi due
per i cavoli nostri siccome noi avevamo
c'è insomma non c'era tanto tempo spar
insanguinata che usciamo tutti quanti
insieme c'è usciva dall'hotel tutti e
quattro poi andavamo dalla parte egitto
di sandoval da un altro che i cieli sono
state volte in cui noi uscivamo facciamo
il giro dell'isolato e rientravamo
nell'otello è già praticamente verdi per
avere andare è successo una volta ci è
andata bene due o tre volte la quarta
nodo 3 volte forse un po troppo una una
volta è andata bene la seconda
nell'albergo abbiamo siamo poi andati
nella
la nostra stanza c'è stata una volta in
cui i genitori sono tornati nel mettere
lui sto ancora nella stanza perché poi
noi dopo aver fatto insomma le nostre
cose sono dovuti uscire perché poi alla
fine i genitori sarebbero di tornare e
noi dopo di loro ok quindi genitori
avrebbero dovuto vederci arrivare da
fuori non da dentro è stata volte in cui
ci hanno veramente fregati ma in una
maniera allucinante
siamo tornati in albergo i genitori
erano usciti mi sono tutt in albergo
abbiamo insomma ha fatto le nostre cose
e poi mentre uscivamo c'era la mamma
della tigre salda che era davanti alla
porta della era davanti alla porta e la
situazione è stata io io non c'ero
grazie a dio in un cero perché poi
appena l'ho vista che era girata non a
vista ma ho detto no vai tu vai tu jong
un vero uomo cavaliere fino a un certo
punto che esalta si è dovuta a subire la
mamma che ovviamente aveva capito perché
come fai a essere in albergo stesso
appena usciti che cosa avete fatto figli
di satana
il giorno dopo dovevamo andare a
gardaland tutti insieme in macchina
io ero in macchina dietro con grease
alda e ci hanno i genitori davanti no
mamma la mamma destra e papà che guidava
in macchina nessuno ha parlato nessuno
ha proferito parola va beh questa è
questa la tia garda insomma questa è
stata questa è stata la nostra insomma
emozioni basta questo video può
concludersi qua anche perché se continua
non ho più la dignità volevo salutare
grezza da che sicuramente avrà guardato
questo video non sto scherzando lo so
che stai gridando pensa io l'ho dovuta
pure raccontare o un viso c'è il mi
stanno vedendo la gente mi guarda mentre
io racconto ste cose cioè immaginatura
conta non sei tra i due quelli in quella
messa peggio e commenta così grazie per
avermi dato il via libera nel per
raccontare questa storia avrei preferito
di no
cioè io te l'ho chiesto posso
raccontarlo a tommy aver saputo
rispondere no non farlo per salvarmi la
vita non è nato per terra anche per me
invece non mi ha detto farvi fai pure io
sono stato
stretto in balia di me stesso a doverla
raccontare va beh grazie grecia da per
questi bei momenti non è colpa tua
neanche mia è colpa del fato del destino
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
iscrivetevi al canale e schiacciate la
campania nina per rimanere aggiornati
stimi video che escono perché mai
l'oreste per darvi un video del genere
ma perché mai ma per quale motivo ma è
schiacciata da tutti i st campanella no
per carità e io vado vado a morire vado
a morire vado a farmi una doccia perché
sarah a raccontare sta cosa mi faccio
vado vado
ciao ragazzi non ci fa sì che cazzo più
di tanto in tanto la porta mela brano lo
stesso con l'attesa
[Musica]